[Aplausos]
[Música]
movilizaciones en el corazón de Lima
manifestantes mancharon en la capital de
Perú en apoyo al presidente Pedro
castillo y pidiendo el cierre del
Congreso
lo único que hacen Esto destruirse del
pueblo que ha sido elegidos
legítimamente que se cierra el congreso
Y si es posible hasta dar la vida hemos
venido decididos pero la escena terminó
el enfrentamientos con la policía
quienes dispararon gases lacrimógenos y
reprimieron con palazos a los miles de
ciudadanos que ocuparon las calles
esto sucede días después de que la
oposición pidiera la inhabilitación de
castillos bajo la acusación de traición
a la patria
acá estamos todos auto convocados acá
son agrupaciones de todas las regiones
Acá hay de las 25 regiones acá estamos
todos auto convocados estamos reclamando
nuestro derecho de nacimiento y vida
porque ya estamos hartos de los
congresistas acomechados que lo único
que hacen es sacar leyes para su
beneficio Castillo ha estado bajo la
mira de la oposición frecuentemente y
evitó dos intentos de juicio político
mientras legisladores buscan apoyo para
iniciar uno nuevo en tanto que el fiscal
general presentó una denuncia contra el
mandatario siendo la primera vez que
sucede en la historia del país la
manifestación sucede 10 días antes de
que la organización de los Estados
Americanos Envía una delegación para
evaluar la situación social y política
de Perú